hi there steve here
um i'm no longer for the time being
doing these um coaching sessions the
90-day challenge is over
um but today i want to talk about
english and i'm gonna do a number of
videos about english
i thought of maybe doing them in spanish
or japanese or some other language
because a lot of people
spanish-speaking people
portuguese-speaking people japanese
speaking chinese speaking russian
speaking
people
learn english
but i will do them in english and i will
speak
slowly
if you use the
captions the subtitles here you can then
import this video into link as a lesson
so that you can hear what i'm saying you
can read what i'm saying
and you can listen to and read some of
the examples that i will give
so that you can work on your english
now
when it comes to english
or any other language
it's possible to write a big long
grammar book and i have such books here
is one which is a very popular book
on english grammar
it has lots of complicated
explanations
exercises on every page
so for example i just open the book here
noun clause
independent clause a clause is a group
of words an independent clause
subordinate clause
the more terms grammar terms
i come up against
the more
confused i get
what i need in learning other languages
is examples
i don't need complicated grammar terms
i need examples of how things are said
or written in the language so that's
what i'm going to try to do in english
in a series of
videos about english
if this is of interest to my viewers
i could also have coaching sessions
just as we had during the 90 day
challenge
where i can talk about some aspect of
english
and people can get on and ask questions
about
things that give them
problems in english
so
today i'm going to talk about
ing
doing giving taking being all of the
different
uh
words in english that end in ing
and some of the problems that people
have with these words now it doesn't
matter whether we call that a gerund or
a verb or a noun
it doesn't matter
what we need to
get a feel for what we need to get used
to is
how do these words work
now
i googled the most common mistakes
you know learners make in english the
most common esl errors you can google
this to see what the most common errors
are if you're interested
ing is on most people's list
i chose the ing as an example
because i had a conversation with a
non-native speaker
and she said i am boring
she may be boring i don't know i don't
find her boring but
what she when she says i am boring she
means that she as a person
is a boring person
of course what she meant to say is i am
bored
okay
and we get this a lot it's a very common
mistake people say for example
i am interesting
i am interesting in movies
that is wrong i am interested
interested not i am interesting
she may be interesting maybe she's
interesting she has a lot to say
that would mean that she is interesting
but usually it's the movie and the book
that are
interesting
and a person is interested
or bored
or excited but not exciting someone may
be exciting but that's for me to say
the person says i am excited about my
trip
so
it's very important and this is a very
common mistake and those words in
particular
boring
interesting exciting
very common for people to get them wrong
if you're talking about
yourself
usually you are bored
or interested or excited
and a movie might be boring the movie is
boring the book is boring the book is
interesting the movie is interesting
i am excited about my trip
or
this is an exciting movie so
that's the first and most obvious place
where people confuse
the ing word
which is
basically the ing word again you call it
gerund or verb or whatever it's kind of
like a state i am something what are you
i am
interesting
the book is interesting
okay whereas if you are interested it's
like actually it's an action i am
interested
i am excited
now in the same conversation this person
said
to improve my english
i have to stop
to read or i think she says stop to read
in spanish i have to stop to read in
spanish that's wrong again i have to
stop reading in spanish
if you stop to read that means you're
walking along and then you stop to read
the sign
stop to do something
whereas you're going to stop reading now
i am sure that in many grammar books you
can find
explanations of all the different
situations where you need to say
stop reading instead of stop to read and
stuff
but and this is a theme
that a message that i will be
repeating
we have to get used to how the language
works
the explanations
are difficult for us to understand
until we already have a lot of
experience with the language so that the
ex the explanation describes something
that we already know all right so the
main thing is to get used to the
language now to get used to the language
if you are a member of link i recommend
and you're dealing with this ing
issue
i think you should save words
save words and phrases that contain the
ing
so
i am going is a phrase
i have been going is a phrase
save all of these phrases
in order to become familiar because the
first step
to getting used to to becoming familiar
with
these
problems that you may have
the first step is to be aware of them to
notice them and you have to help
yourself to notice them and we're going
to be in the next few videos if these
videos are
interesting to you
then
i will be giving you many examples and
you should
try to remember some of these examples
the other thing you can do if you're not
a member of link is you can google
so google
am interesting
google am boring and see what you get
you won't get
natural english phrases you'll get some
explanations
about why this is a mistake whereas if
you google
am interested
and doing you'll see lots of examples of
these phrases in use in natural contexts
so
these kinds of activities
googling the mistaken
phrase googling the correct phrase
or saving phrases at link
are all going to help you notice
and that's where it starts start by
noticing
and the other thing is
you know you're not going to be perfect
overnight in english so if you can focus
on one problem at a time
you know put your energy and effort into
noticing and developing good habits
about one problem and then the next
problem gradually your english will
become more natural so i will continue
these
uh videos if there's interest and i look
forward to hearing from you bye for now
you